Hey there everyone, I'm at CERN in Geneva
Now CERN's famous for like the Large Hadron Collider and all that physics, but it's also famous for something else
which I'm sure a lot of you are thinking of and
Just in there is a really cool sort of piece of history come and follow me and I'll show you
Here we go where the web was born
So basically this corridor is where the world wide web was developed Sean the coder
Pretty cool. Let me summarize this because it's quite detailed
basically, it says around 1990 in a couple of other buildings Tim berners-lee among the others came up with the ideas and then in
91 it was all pretty much consolidated to this corridor
so
Look at these guys
Desecrating a sacred site. Basically this corridor still used. It's still a working place for CERN
This isn't a museum or anything you look at all these officers off to the sides people just doing their work
But it was here from 91 onwards that Tim berners-lee
And his team developed the world wide web here at CERN all to do with accessing documents and things like that
We all know what it's become since and it was around 94
That these people basically broke off from CERN and developed the web proper, but it all started here
Pretty cool. Hey
And
Those are the actual pipes that the internet travels down
So if I turn this here that will turn the internet off. I better not touch that
From your office and it can end up on a computer that's
completely at the other end of the world and then comes back to you with the result and all this demand that exists at
Different points of the world at different times of day is then equalized so that this whole structure is used efficiently
So this is like the most advanced organization on earth where the worldwide web was invented and that's the telephone